[Music]
you know show it's my favorite show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
that's enough of this stuff I am back
from vacation and I've got so much stuff
to talk to you about i streamed on i
streamed on YouTube yesterday I was gone
all of last week there were no live
streams and I am actually fully fully
back until Monday obviously the Labor
Day holiday I'll be taking off but I'm
back at least for this week so oh is it
too bright people are shocked by the
brightness of my room doing the twitch
stream did YouTube yesterday I had to
kind of rearrange I forgot that the chat
which makes sense on which makes sense
on Twitch did not make sense on YouTube
and so I put super chats up and it was
chaos it didn't work that well but in
any case I'm back on Twitch and
hopefully we've I don't want to lose the
momentum that I built last week last
last couple of weeks and in fact our
subscriber number is now starting to
crash because I'm at exactly one month
one month in two days since I started on
Twitch this the follower numbers are
going great subscribers though are
starting to fall off because all of
those twitch prime subscriptions are
starting to fall off where did I have
that oh yeah here so here's our
followers on Twitch in any case people
suggesting that I actually do side by
side twitch and YouTube live subscriber
a follower account I don't know why but
it's something I can do and it doesn't
seem that interesting but maybe we'll go
back to that later and have some kind of
contest I don't know please subscribe
with twitch prime if your subscription
has fallen off and I've actually there
should be a button on the stell me if
there's a button on the screen that says
free sub ready because I installed some
kind of thing I don't know that's
supposed to let people know when their
twitch prime thing is avail
is that there Oh gifts are coming in Oh
turkey bacon and cheese is here that's
awesome turkey bacon and cheese
requesting later streams because they
are in a part of the world where they
benefit from later streams East Coast
time and we're doing it we're making it
happen very very exciting stuff so thank
you turkey bacon and she's giving out
twenty20 tier one community sub gifts
and surely underscore subscribing with
prime and young double underscore dad
subscribing with twitch prime okay if
people want me to I have tons of stuff
planned for today and I'll tell you
about some of it momentarily
I have copious notes but if people want
me to open the phone lines I will do it
if we get 15 new website members okay
the count is up there in the upper right
of the screen info for where to sign up
is right down there bottom centre coupon
codes are available there's an even more
exclusive coupon code which is half 19
which will save you 50% instead of 40%
but it's on the honor system if you want
to take the the discount you can but you
don't have to yeah people shocked I'm
making notes I'm taking twitch seriously
I was actually on the surfs earlier
today and did like an hour interview on
the surfs
and we were talking about like what is
the plan for twitch and the plan is if
we keep getting things out of twitch I
will keep putting time and energy into
twitch and I actually have a whole list
of possible things to do on Twitch
there's no set schedule right now but I
have a lot of ideas and every every
stream I do shockingly to some I'm
actually planning this in advance and
it's still this unorganized okay if
people are unable to renew their
memberships I guess that maybe it's
still active
I don't know CMV 970 thanks for gifting
a tier 1 sub 2 long socks and Zee Linus
thanks for subscribing with twitch Prime
and CMV 970 thank you for cheering one
bit I very very much appreciate that
so let's see a couple of things I want
to play this so during my interview with
the serfs this isn't even it hold on
where am i this is it okay so I was told
that I was told that sargon of akkad
appear so the way that this came up is
thanks silent Watson for hosting by the
way I mentioned to Lance that it seems
like Sargon is kind of not that relevant
like I haven't really heard anything
about him for the last year and Lance
said that Sargon appeared with alex
jones and i want to watch that so we're
gonna be watching that momentarily
already mentioned please remember to
subscribe with twitch prime if your
subscription has expired
I've got we have kind of a cool
promotion coming up I'm not gonna show
the brand yet because we're still
finalizing it actually maybe I shouldn't
even do this yeah I'm not gonna do this
actually we have a new promotion with a
watch company coming up that they're
making a really nice commitment to my
podcast and TV show but before it seems
that I was gonna show you the watches
but there's really no way to show you
the watches without it being obvious
what brand it is so I'm not gonna do
that but soon I'll have some interesting
watch stuff and in fact maybe I will
give away two nice watches for people on
twitch if it keeps being the place for
streaming which it sort of seems to be I
also later we'll talk about home I can't
even read my own notes oh right so
Hassan Hassan is banned I learned
because of his 9/11 comments from twitch
for seven days is that right this all
happened while I was on vacation and I
started getting texts from mutual
friends of ours saying did you hear what
happened to with Hassan and I hadn't and
I looked it up during my vacation and it
sort of ruined my vacation unfortunately
but I'll have that out with Hassan at
some point in the future and if
someone's saying he got banned for
making fun of a bit of a veteran all
right well I guess I don't know I guess
I don't know why you got banned change
the category to just chatting oh I
thought I wasn't just chatting let me
change that category just chatting
update okay I changed it hopefully
that'll bring in some more people the
band will be over soon okay yeah so
anyway I was hoping to check in with
Hassan cuz he I got to Aruba last week
and the day I got there it was on a
weekend I get a message from her son
saying hey do you want to go on ROG
today and I said I'm on vacation in a
roubo with no streaming equipment I am
up for doing it if people let me know in
advance I've got to kind of like plan
around it but I am I am willing to do it
I'm not even gonna repeat what people
are saying Hassan said yeah I know I
can't have him on until he's back on I'm
not even gonna repeat what people are
saying he said because I don't know what
the rules are and I don't I don't want
to get in trouble okay let's get in if
people are okay with it so I have a few
things I was going to do I want to check
out this Sargon with Alex Jones thing if
people are into that I was potentially
gonna take people told me that there's
another test they want me to take the
political court and it's test on IDR
labs it's only 36 questions and then I
guess it's a people want to see my
results there we can look at recent
clips that I've uploaded there's an
article I bookmarked why it was easier
to be skinny in the 1980s haven't read
it yet but I'm up for checking it out
with you fine folks and then we can look
at what's happening on my subreddit as
well the memes are coming in fast and
furious and then again I think people
wanted this site that need to do this
side by side I don't even know what the
idea is of seeing whether we can get
more twitch or YouTube followers slash
subscribers during the stream clearly
since I started streaming the number on
twitch is going up I don't fully know
what the point of this is but people
have asked me to to do this so I guess
I'll go back to that to the extent
people are interested in it okay let me
do just some last thank-yous and then
we're going to get started let me see
where I am
oh and let me so okay actually before I
even do this let me just mention again
we have one new website member Frank
Jenna Vaizey Genevieve Genovese Jenna
Vasi and I will get us to one of 15 the
counter up there is merely website
member
okay website members meaning you go to
join pakman.com and you sign up that's
like the number one funding source for
my show and usually we do some kind of
challenge often the number is 15 and if
we get to 15 website members I'll open
up the phone lines and people can call
and we've got 1 1 of 15 so far it's
really easy you drag the slider you can
do yearly or monthly you hit sign up
coupon codes like for example if I type
half 19 $6 a month
becomes $3 a month it's a beautiful
thing we keep 97.1% of every payment
that's more than we keep I know I'm not
supposed to say what percentage is
different platforms take 97.1% is more
than we keep on any other platform so
that's what website memberships are and
that is what will potentially get us to
open the phone lines
okay thanks the real Birdo for cheering
a hundred bits thanks to s Troxel Troxel
6611 for subscribing with twitch prime
thanks to Jigen 432
Jurgen G gen for subscribing with twitch
Prime and thanks to Kirsch Moe for
cheering one bit okay let's get to let's
take a listen to this let's see what's
happened what happened with Sargon on to
the Alex Jones Show we don't want to
hear from this guy let's see it's fast
forward to where the Sargon part starts
oh god also no no wait let me back up oh
no what is Christine Blasi forward a
helium balloon in a wig it's all the
press attention 30 women testifying
against a convicted pedophile sex
trafficker and the diseases developed
Alden I don't know who this guy is but
he's developed all of the same
mannerisms and even like weird tics of
Alex Jones that's interest mention it
why because Epstein had top Democrats
and it leads on his list
whoa before we even go further our JC
has cheered 5,000 bits and instantly is
in competition with turkey bacon and
cheese for the all-time top cheers only
1500 bits now separate turkey bacon and
G and cheese and our JC RJC thank you
really a lot for cheering 5,000 bits up
if people are asking if I'm gonna cover
and II know from Colette I have a video
on my youtube channel right now right
here so I haven't been talking much a
bit and I encourage you to check that
out but later cuz I'm streaming right
now okay here we go are gone a cod also
known as Carl it's all Sargon Akkad Oh
half a second has confirmed to me that
Alex Jones has no idea who he's talking
to here okay let's continue as millions
and millions of followers on YouTube and
other platforms is that true does he
have millions and millions of followers
let me look that up Sargon of Akkad
YouTube I would be shocked if he had
does he even is his YouTube channel even
around I can't even find it Sargon of
Akkad YouTube I literally can't even
find his channel Sargon of Akkad oh here
it is okay he has nine hundred and sixty
eight thousand subscribers not exactly
millions and millions but okay fair
enough
let's continue he's also bendy platform
some places and he's with us
now in studio to just talk about the
world of the place it's in right now and
where he thinks these revolutions of
populism versus but what would you call
it globalism are going thanks for coming
is his chair lower than Alex Jones
because the Sargon seems to me not like
the thinnest guy he looks tiny next to
Alex Jones maybe it's just the height of
their chairs that are different I don't
know video was been a fan of your work
for a while
hard to believe so first off you're
handled Sargon where does that name come
from
it comes from a Middle Eastern Emperor I
didn't I didn't think anything was ever
gonna come of anything when I first
started uploading videos to YouTube and
so I just used it because it was the
tags that I used when I was playing
video games on there's no way that
Sargon of Akkad is 5'4 for my report
tell me that that there's just no pie
I'm not taller than anyone I meet other
than maybe well I'm not even gonna say
but there's no way that sorry Sargon of
Akkad has got to be like twice my size
completely you know spacious no thought
put into whatsoever and if I can go back
and redo it i just use my real name well
it's good to have you here with us thank
you you were on yesterday did a great
job with owens troy or covered some of
the big breaking news but shop
commercial 3 here right now what do you
want to get into today what's front and
center for you
somehow alex jones managed to put a
sound into the word free i don't know
how you do that but he did um well at
the moment I'm doing a part two to the
Jeffrey Epstein video I just did
I'd laser taking quite a lot of time
because there's a lot of stuff happening
and a lot of strange information coming
out about the whole case the the fact
that he had broken bones in his throat
that were broken in such a way this to
indicate that was most likely strangling
rather than choking on a paper thin
sheet from his bunk bed that that's
particularly interesting to me because
and especially he says his cellmate was
moved out of the cell the day before he
died and all this it's it's all very
very suspect
and but we're hearing from the new
Attorney General that oh it probably was
suicide I mean I find that very very
suspicious when Epstein told people that
that the previous cellmate had tried to
basically kill him he told people that
he feared for his life and then it just
have the media say it's a conspiracy
theory out of the gates not to question
it that it doesn't hold water
you have much room to cool people
conspiracy theorists off of the whole
Russia thing but I agree there is
definitely something to this and there
is definitely it's definitely easy for
them if it just goes away where are you
in a gut level and I know you're not a
guy that even theorizes you just go in
the fact he doesn't theorize yeah that's
an interesting one I'm gonna skip ahead
because I abstain so I want to see other
stuff let's see people who failed before
them were just doing it wrong and that
they'll do better
Jordan Peterson actually really nails it
this you know you are not competent
enough to enact a system that is as
all-controlling as it needs to be to
achieve your dream because they do have
a utopian goal in mind and it's I mean
centralizing an entire country an entire
economy the entire civilization is it's
such a it's an arrogant thing to want to
do use even a view that computers that
could do it the humans won't be able to
program and/or control it and then it
removes us from the decision-making
process which will only make us more
domesticated well yeah but even then why
should we agree with it you know that
why should we and it is as you say you
who are actually giving up your freedom
your liberty by allowing that to happen
I don't agree I think that I should be
able to own property I think that it's
not the domain of someone else to take
that profit I'll know what I'm hiding
when both people shared the same myopic
and
it's sort sort of I don't even know what
other words to use to qualify it but
it's it's quite boring actually it's
it's fun when it's like Alex Jones
talking to you know Piers Morgan or
something like that because of the
contrast but there's something here yeah
it's the same mantra pragmatic tactician
it's the same I don't even know what to
describe it but I'm finding this
actually quite boring let's see I don't
see why I should give that up what is
your view of the whole situation
happening right now in Hong Kong I'm
very worried about what's gonna happen
in Hong Kong I'm sure I'm sure the
protesters there has been occasion where
the protesters have done something
that's maybe on the wrong side of the
law like cutting down the the monitoring
the the facial recognition cameras and
things like this you could argue this
illegal well I suppose technically it is
but the the consequences from the
Chinese government are going to be a lot
worse than anything the protesters have
been all of them will have been able to
justify from what the protesters have
done frankly I wouldn't trust the
Chinese government at all well I agree
100% and I want to just clarify for
viewers because I've made a study of
history because it's so interesting not
so I can sit around and show off a
little understanding of a wide range of
things Hong Kong Taiwan you know going
back to World War two what's weird about
this is what is Alex Jones know about
Hong Kong what does Carl Benjamin know
about Hong Kong it's like what are these
guys talking about let's see what else
they discuss oh it's frozen now
we may have lost the feed in my country
about 35% of people are actively opposed
to feminism rather than just like there
we go it's not that they're not feminist
is they oppose feminism like there is a
much broader section of the population
that as opposed this and part of it is
as you say women are attracted to
masculinity they do like masks they
don't tend to go for feminine men so I
don't know why I have to say that it
seems obvious doesn't it but that's the
reality of it and you can see by the
polling and yet the feminists are not
happy about this but the whole the whole
drive behind all of it this is one of
those things where this is how people
get read pilled with just the stupid
stuff like listen to what he just said
by the way yeah people pointing out that
Sargon looks a little weird here that
something strange seems to be going on
with him obviously something strange
going on with Alex Jones I don't know so
Sargon said as a counterpoint to
feminism he said listen women prefer
masculine men and it's like okay yeah I
mean heterosexual women who are
attracted to men are going to be
attracted to men that they identify as
masculine I mean this is it's it's sort
of like one of these things where you're
saying something that's true but it in
no way relates to the failings and
successes of feminism or validates or
invalidates feminism as an ideology or
adjudicates different types of like it's
it's one of these things where people
hear this thing they go [ __ ] I mean Alex
Jones and Sargon are making a lot of
sense here feminism must be terrible
because heterosexual women respond to
men they identify as being men because
that's what they're attracted to it is
down to equality they think that
masculinity is a they know that it's a
it's a it's an upward force it it's
creative it's exploratory it's
aggressive it's not going to end up with
equality but it is going to end up with
things like success and excitement and
things like this
but that's not equality you know and so
they have to drag that down to make the
men the same as the women but that drags
everybody down yes it does I mean again
men can't have babies but there's this
mental illness where they go oh look
this man's having a baby
but it's a woman that transitioned you
know what it's starting to ohm it's
almost starting to get where I'm worried
I don't even know that I want this stuff
on my stream because it's it's like
getting just so transphobic that I don't
even know that it I don't know exactly
the rules I know I'm not saying this
stuff but our people I mean we don't
need to watch the rest of this right I
think we sort of have an understanding
of what's going on and if truly if
Sargon is five for I am just shocked by
that I'm truly truly shocked by that
move on would rather not okay yeah we
know that that's right that jerk James
is saying we know everything that
they're going to say we don't need to
see this very good okay well next I'm
gonna go to i'll take the political
coordinates tests next but first let me
thank some people first of all thank you
to sir graves for the twitch Prime
subscription I appreciate that
if you see on your screen something that
says what does it say subscription ready
or something like that please click it
and subscribe to my twitch channel with
twitch prime thank you to turkey bacon
and cheese who has cheered 5001 bits
upstaging rj c who cheered 5,000 and
also jumping to a significant lead in
the all-time top cheers with eleven
thousand five hundred and one oh someone
says that they argue about gay frogs
near the end let me just try to find
that because that actually sounds kind
of fine just so i'm gonna be captain
i'll be the first results just like I
used to be on Google before my MEP
campaign how was the first result on
Google if you typed in song and Mehcad I
had usurped the position of the
historical one but now you can't
actually find my youtube channel or
videos that way you have to type in
sargon of akkad youtube specifically
he's right they just action on that
ledge and then when you're going let's
see if we can find the dangerous it's
gonna be a very tumultuous time but at a
gut level I think classical liberalism
is going to come back in in the near
future and I think it's gonna be
populace to nationalists that embrace it
that'll end up being the new
intellectual elite and I think we're
gonna see a new dawn and a new
Renaissance I mean I think that's the
very possible probable outcome if we do
our jobs and keep fighting in art
well let's hope so what do you think I
don't even want to think about the
future I just want to think about what's
right in front of my face because my god
I don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow it's been this is so boy I'm
sorry I'm out I just I have to get out
okay let me take this test whew okay
when people of some people are asking
like bike Gaeta he's asking how to
subscribe via Amazon Prime correct me if
I'm wrong first you have to connect your
Amazon Prime account to twitch Prime I
think if you google how to do that it's
easy and then you just hit the purple
subscribe with twitch Prime button up in
the corner right like over there
somewhere is that the is that the right
explanation for people correct yeah oh
boy there is a cheer
penis size contest going on much to my
benefit our JC has cheered 10,000 bits
and has surpassed turkey bacon and
cheese since day one since day one
people are going crazy in the chat we're
gonna have to bring in 10 more mods
because people are getting so wound up
since day one of my twitch stream turkey
bacon and cheese has been the top cheer
he has just been upstaged by our JC who
has rocketed with 15,000 bits to the
all-time top cheer okay things are
happening so quickly I can't even tell
but turkey bacon and cheese is now back
with four thousand nine hundred and
ninety nine bits and is up to five
fifteen thousand it's a tie but now I I
can't even see where these things are
coming in now uh-oh ice no turkey bacon
and cheese now is back in the lead with
sixteen thousand five hundred and
marxist-leninist
is completely titillated by what's going
on which is which is absolutely
fascinating thanks to so triggered for
subscribing with twitch prime thanks to
see robin for subscribing with twitch
prime and thanks to d mart for
subscribing with twitch prime very much
appreciate it
what are bits i have no idea but when
people subscribe
Julian tars knee is the second website
member of the evening we are now up to 2
of 15 and if we get to 15 website
members I will open up the phone lines
I'm gonna take this political court in
its test I'm kidding I know that bits
art which currency P some people
genuinely think I don't know what I'm
talking about
and and they're right but I do know what
bits are okay so let's uh I'll do the
political coordinate stats test next
feel free to take this with me the way
to find this is you go to IDR labs.com
then you click on tests and then you go
to political test okay so let's say it's
only 36 questions let's just do it I'm
gonna look away from the chat while I do
this and then I will get back to it
everybody will be thanked don't worry if
an immigrant wants to fly the flag of
his home country on my country soil
that's okay with me
yeah I don't care about that
rehabilitating criminals is more
important than punishing them I think
sometimes you can't rehabilitate but I
do believe absolutely that
rehabilitation is more important than
punishing in terms of if you imagine if
you say if you could choose between
punishing every criminal or
rehabilitating them what would better
serve society rehabilitation would of
course serve society better overall
security leaks like those perpetrated by
Edward Snowden and WikiLeaks do more
harm than good
no I don't it's it's there are certain
leaks that do more harm than good and
certain ones that do more good than harm
and then you've got to balance the
legality I'm just gonna leave this one
in the middle
government spending with the aim of
creating jobs is generally a good idea I
tend to agree with that I am a
demand-side stimulus guy I'm not a
supply-side ER but I don't agree with it
I'm gonna go one one I'm gonna go over
one but not I guess I'm agreeing but not
strongly agreeing it is legitimate for
nations to privilege their own religion
over others what is legitimate mean
legitimate in that I agree with it
legitimate in that in some legal sense I
mean this is a really poorly worded
question the way that a lot of these are
so I guess I guess I'll leave it in the
middle Western civilization has
benefited more from Christianity than
from the ideas of ancient Greece I think
I'm gonna disagree I think that even
though we don't often realize it much of
the infrastructure for even how we think
about issues is based on the ideas of
ancient Greece surveillance and
counterterrorism programs have gone too
far I agree with that
capital punishment should be an option
in some cases I am against capital
punishment for a dozen different reasons
some peoples and religions are generally
more trouble than others I mean yes it
is true in in principle oftentimes
people get the specifics wrong but I do
agree with that it almost never ends
well when the government gets involved
in business strongly disagree if the
government is not involved in business
you know libertarians will tell you
businesses are incentivized to police
themselves and it's a joke it's a joke
immigration to my country should be
minimized and strictly controlled not in
principle I mean listen I I believe in
borders I believe that if everyone
decides they want to go to one country
the country becomes unsustainable but
the question is on what basis I'm gonna
leave this one in the middle the minimum
wage does more harm than good
disagree equality is more important than
economic growth no it's not more
important but it's not less important
prostitution should be legal I tend to
believe that it should i I don't
strongly agree with it but I do lean in
that direction
okay the chat has gotten my attention
cuz a lot of crazy things are going on
let me see what we've got happening here
pragmatic tactician cheered one bit and
then RJC cheered five thousand bits once
again taking the lead over
turkey bacon and cheese our JC has now
cheered 20,000 bits all today thank you
and has taken the lead for all time top
cheerer
over turkey bacon and cheese extremely
exciting extremely exciting stuff that's
going on okay a strong military is a
better foreign policy tool than strong
diplomacy I disagree but not strongly
you need a military but I think the
prone to diplomacy is stronger the
government should provide health care to
its citizens free of charge well listen
free of charge seems to suggest you're
not paying for it at all the government
should provide health care to its
citizens free at the point of sale but
paid for through taxation instead of
premiums and co-pays and all of that
stuff if that is implied as long socks
is saying then I will strongly agree
monarchy and aristocratic titles should
be abolished I don't care about the
aristocratic titles I do think monarchy
should be abolished I will agree but not
strongly if people want to drive without
a seat belt that should be their
decision
I disagree you can fly out and hurt
someone else who is wearing their seat
belts so I disagree with that the market
is generally better at allocating
resources than the government it depends
where I don't so you know free-market
capitalists would say that the market is
generally better in all areas socialists
and communists might say the government
is better in all areas I'm going to
leave this one in the middle because it
really depends what you're talking about
my country should give more foreign aid
and development aid to third-world
countries
you know I'm not huge in agreement on
this not because I'm against helping
countries but because I've read a lot
about how foreign and developmental aid
often does not actually help countries
to develop and become self-sufficient so
I'm gonna leave that in the middle some
countries and civilizations are natural
enemies I disagree with that I think
that it might appear that way because of
how history has unfolded but there is
nothing so fixed about
people who turn down a job should not be
eligible for unemployment benefits from
the government no I disagree with that
there's all sorts of legitimate reasons
why one would turn down a job and that
that's I'm not this is just not my
ideology marijuana should believe be
legal of course import tariffs on
foreign products are a good way to
protect jobs in my country you know
we're seeing right now that they're not
now now strictly speaking import tariffs
can protect jobs but there is always a
cost and right now we are in an
incredible endless escalating trade war
with China that is extremely damaging
and it's not so good actually for jobs
farmers are getting completely crushed
so I'm going to disagree ok I'm 2/3 of
the way through let me just follow up
with what's happening in the chat
pragmatic tactician has cheered 9 bits
thank you I appreciate that and I also
want to wow it's I don't know that we're
getting the phones opened we are still
stuck at only 2 of 15 website members
today if folks don't want the phones
opened keep doing what you're doing
you're absolutely doing the right thing
but if people do want the phones open
please sign up on my website join
pakman.com ok speculation on the stock
exchange is less desirable than other
kinds of economic activity I agree with
that it is less desirable there is a
heart of there is at heart a conflict
between the interest of business and the
interest of society at heart I'm trying
to deal with at heart the way that our
version of capitalism exists does create
that conflict I don't think that it is
at heart and I will disagree the
government should redistribute wealth
from the rich to the poor to some degree
I believe that that is true I'm a social
democrat we need to increase taxes on
industry out of concern for the climate
I agree that that is actually something
that will be effective in mitigating
climate change a country should never go
to war without the support of the
international community I'm gonna
disagree but only because of the word
never
there are situations if someone is truly
at an existential risk where you could
have the international community simply
not agreeing and you may need to go to
war although I see war as a last resort
of course there are too many wasteful
government programs there are wasteful
government programs this is a popular
right wing talking point I'm gonna leave
this one neutral overall labor unions do
more harm than good
I disagree homosexual couples should
have all the same rights as heterosexual
couples including the right to adopt of
course they should taxpayer money should
not be spent on arts or sports disagree
contributes to the fabric of society
creates engaged well-rounded citizens
and residents medically assisted suicide
should be legal I agree although it's
not super strong but I do agree I
actually know a lot of doctors who are
not big on it and they've made what are
somewhat compelling cases but I do agree
the government should set a cap on wages
of bankers and CEOs I'm really mixed on
this you know so my immediate instinct
is there should be lots of other things
done such that we wouldn't even be
having this conversation in other words
I we could we could do other things that
would make it so we don't need to cap
wages of bankers and CEOs I understand
why someone would want to I actually I'm
gonna say I disagree with that free
trade is better for third-world
countries than developmental hey this is
so complicated it depends on which
country depends on what type of aid
depends on what type of trade so I'm
gonna leave it in the middle okay
I'll just wait a moment or two to allow
people to catch up and then we will look
at my results thanks to can a 72 for
cheering one bit let me look at people
who have been sending donations and
comments with them because I sometimes
forget those oh Ken a says I found this
bit between the couch cushions I
appreciate that pragmatic tactician said
why are conservatives against socialism
but when it comes to the military the
biggest example of good
communal work and goals it is supported
by them it's not just the military
actually where they support what is
effectively socialism but yes that's a
good point
our JC o RJC sent a comment with his
5,000 his or her 5,000 bits right this
is not a battle I will lose I can't
think of anything more important to do
with my money well then let's start the
insanity pragmatic tactician says what
are my thoughts on weapon rights and
ownership we have a second amendment
that's the reality that being said I
think we should have 100% universal
background checks for all gun
transactions there should be a waiting
period for gun purchases you should be
required to carry gun insurance
ammunition should be expensive and there
are a whole bunch of other things that I
would do let's see here pizza but asked
of things are scrolling now can I talk
about Hillary joining the race now
keeping it still 20 candidates I've not
heard of Hillary joining the race if I
miss that end up please let me know are
JC with the 10,000 [ __ ] here said let's
do a beta male dick-measuring contest
that sounds delightful let's do it and a
bunch of cheers mcglue says great job
David okay I think I'm mostly caught up
over there what are my thoughts about in
cells someone wants to know but it's sad
it's sad David you realize
live-streaming is one word right yeah
what did I do
I'm back to live stream oh I see yeah I
don't know I think in that context it
might be two words the terror master has
subscribed with twitch prime listen if
you subscribed last month with with
twitch Prime on the 26th or the 27th and
your twitch Prime subscription has
dropped off because they don't
automatically renew please renew it
right now I would appreciate that before
you forget okay I'm gonna look at my
results now let's see political
coordinates tests your your political
coordinates are 30 percent left 36
percent liberal so I'm in the left
liberal quadrant not surprising
and I am according to this somewhere I
guess to the left of Bill Clinton and
more liberal over communit more
libertarian than Barack Obama can anyone
understand this explanation of quadrants
okay so I'm in the blue quadrant let's
read about that left liberalism social
liberalism individuals in this quadrant
seek to uphold individual liberty while
taxing the market to provide social
benefits for those in need that's true
they see themselves as seeking balance
between liberty and justice to be in
favor of multiculturalism secular
government and international cooperation
yes while they are typically skeptical
of state involvement in social affairs
they see a legitimate role for the state
in combating discrimination and ensuring
equal treatment yep that's basically me
who put Obama there yeah I disagree that
Obama is here in my mind Obama should be
much closer to Bill Clinton I don't know
that that is the right spot BuzzFeed
quizzes next please not sure man
okay so we dealt with that maybe we'll
do the Andino thing next I don't know I
don't know about watching our own videos
here okay oh we have the continued
battle between turkey bacon and cheese
and RJC turkey bacon and cheese cheered
3501 bits but RJC has cheered another
5,000 bits and RJC still leads the
all-time cheers by 4999 4999 when i see
turkey bacon and cheese i don't because
I don't eat pork I don't see it as
Turkey comma bacon comma and cheese I
see it as turkey bacon and cheese tell
me if people agree disagree with that
okay it's weird it's a weird stream
tonight alright so let me do okay so let
me tell you are confused about what I
mean by do I keep kosher no I don't I
don't it's I being the reason I don't
eat pork has nothing to do
religion its what is the reason I don't
even remember now
no it's listen I don't eat whale I would
not eat dolphin
I don't eat dog pigs are right up there
in terms of intelligence and sociability
and it also it seems to genuinely not be
good health-wise to eat pork something
about the digestive system so pork is
out have not had any pork for a very
very long time
I don't eat people and as far as my
thoughts on veganism I don't care what
people do be vegan doesn't bother me
Tommy pickles has subscribed with twitch
Prime and I appreciate that okay so
here's the deal with website membership
all right there's all these different
ways that you can support the work that
I do
there's cheering with bits there is
subscribing with twitch Prime getting a
twitch subscription YouTube super chats
YouTube subscription patreon I won't go
into details because I don't want to get
in trouble but every single one of those
has a fee if you send me a dollar I
don't get the dollar I get some fraction
of the dollar and it's a bigger fraction
than a lot of people would imagine
because I don't control any of those
platforms this website I control 100%
all we pay is 2.9 percent 2.9 percent
from each membership payment we keep
97.1% that's very solid so if you want
to subscribe for example here's what I
would do because this is such a good
deal six bucks a month that's 72 dollars
for the year you don't have to do that
okay switch to yearly hit the signup
button and then type in the coupon code
half nineteen that'll set you up for an
entire year for 30 bucks okay when you
have a membership one of the things you
get is member content member content
includes bonus shows all of these bonus
shows become available to you the bonus
show is only available for paid
subscribers this is great stuff but even
if you don't care about the extra
content you're supporting the work that
we do in a way that you know nothing can
happen to this right we can lose all of
these other different platforms they can
D monetize
they could kick us off I might say the
wrong thing somebody might get you know
an f-bomb or the other f-bomb and then I
get in trouble who the hell knows and
this is something that they can't touch
if we get 13 more website subscribers I
will open phone lines now people are
asking what does it mean to open phone
lines we have a phone number the phone
number is six one seven eight three zero
47 50 I will turn off I will enable the
phone line I will turn off voicemail and
then you can call in and talk to me and
I will take phone calls this is not a
lot of money it really supports the work
we do and that's why I talk about it
okay
do people want me to play my Andy no
analysis at 1.5 X speed from today
because a lot of people are asking about
Andy no or do you want me to go through
this article why it was easier to be
skinny in the 1980s which I have not yet
read so do you want Andy no or do you
want skinny people seem to want the Andy
no thing some people want skinny oh I'm
interesting now it's now the skinny
brigade is coming in I'll do both of
them it's just you know which one am I
gonna do first people's one person wants
me to read the foundations of Leninism
I'm not gonna do that on stream anyway
how do I do a straw poll yeah I have no
idea how to do that is that is that an
add-on of some kind reduce capital on
stream yeah that'll be fun
Google straw poll okay why don't why not
oh okay I got it
which do I do first Andy no video or
skinny article let's see create poll and
then got it okay so let me paste the
link I'm pasting the link into the chat
there it is
let's see who says what here oh this is
in real time this is cool okay Wow
pasting it again I feel like now people
are voting for the skinny article just
for kicks
don't show it on streem oh okay gotcha
yeah people are gonna try to 50/50 it I
get it
should have realized that all right it's
off screen now Wow as soon as I took it
off screen it is starting to go
drastically drastically in one direction
all right I'm gonna give it 10 more
seconds and then that's gonna be it okay
people want the Andino video first which
is totally fine all right let's do that
all right let's so this was my
commentary from earlier today people
asking about what I've been saying about
and you know I'm not gonna repeat it
let's just watch together out this
right-wing journalist named Andy no it's
spelled NGO I've been told it's
pronounced no I'm going to pronounce it
that way today I'm gonna talk about him
today a little bit now I know for a fact
that a significant portion of my
audience has not even heard of this guy
they're not aware of the controversy
involving Andy no but at this point I
think it does warm it a discussion even
if you haven't been following the story
because Andy know is just the worst kind
of sorry sorry I forgot to turn on a
dark mode here evening grifter that's
what I've learned over the last couple
of months on explaining the entire thing
to Andy know is an early 30s 30 to 33
year old right-wing journalist his
parents came to the United States from
Vietnam he's an Asian American he was
born and raised in the United States in
Portland Oregon and he was known prior
to June of 2019 in some circles for
writing for a publication named Colette
and in June he was propelled to
significantly more notoriety and fame
because he was assaulted at a protest by
an Tifa protestors in Portland Oregon
there was a right-wing proud boy March
in Portland Oregon there was an MC I've
got to say I don't really watch my show
often the show is looking pretty good
lately I
actually I'm feeling pretty good about
the look of the broadcast protests and
Andino was there and he was attacked he
was punched he was milkshakes I mean
really bad stuff I unconditionally
denounced it I haven't talked more about
the broader and enos tough but the
attacks on him I denounced I'm against
violence it's horrible we shouldn't be
doing this to anyone a period okay and
people were saying oh and Ino was
baiting and Tifa to attack him merely by
being there because people know what
he's written in the past okay but that
all may be true but the violence is
completely out of line I'm against the
violence period horrible full stop and
no other qualifiers are necessary
now when that happened when he was
attacked of course predictably he
immediately got media round of
interviews as a result and the media
interviews mostly set him up to talk
about how violent the left is and how
bad an Tifa is he was on Dave Reubens
show he was on Joe Rogan's show I think
he was on Fox News he was all over the
place and fascinatingly a lot of the
coverage was identity politics coverage
saying look at this small in stature gay
Asian guy who was attacked by left
wingers even though he checks identity
boxes that the left should be defending
or or in favor of or whatever I mean
it's a total identity politics argument
we know that the right claims to be
against identity politics except when
they're for it
because it benefits them in some way
shape or form but then things started to
sort of not make sense about antinos so
first of all he had claimed that the
Milkshakes that were thrown at him which
I'm against period the milkshakes that
were thrown at him contained concrete
which of course would conceivably Harden
and do serious damage to a human body
but there appears to be no actual
evidence that there was any concrete
there so that started to be sort of a
weird thing then I asked myself when I
watched interviews with this guy why
does him you know sort of speak in a
British accent now when if you look at
videos from just a few years ago he had
a standard American accent and he was
raised in Portland Oregon is no crime to
adopt a random accent we know it was at
Madonna has gone right but the people
that do that it's an odd thing to do and
often for me it signals that there may
be there's more to the person it's rare
that all they do that raises questions
is adopt an accent that doesn't
correspond to where they were raised
okay but then it gets really bad
journalistically okay and Ino starts
reporting that at another Portland
Oregon protest and Tifa attacked
right-wingers with hammers he tweeted
and Tifa attacks people on a bus they
try to pull them out and hit him with a
hammer and from the video he posted it
sort of maybe seems plausible but very
quickly more videos surfaced and you
actually see that the antiva people we
might call them the counter protesters
were pounding on the windows of a bus
containing right-wingers from the white
nationalist group and it's actually the
right-wingers in the bus who introduced
a hammer literally the opposite of what
this guy and II know reports and the
people
on the bus again they were either
right-wing American Guard which is a
right-wing supremacist white supremacist
group or maybe proud boys or a
combination of the two so the story let
me pause right here because people are
asking a good question can I show you an
example of the accent change I can let's
take a look at it oh and it's gone okay
very good
so there was actually a tweet which had
his before and after accent and now it's
gone so if people let me know that's two
paths in any case we'll continue the
opposite of what and II know reports and
then what and II know follows up with is
all right it was the right wingers who
introduced the hammers but they were
doing it in self defense which is have a
completely different story I mean really
a grifter tweeting quote the mob rush to
the buses as they were trying to leave
and began attacking the vehicles with
concrete before attacking the people
inside the buses could not continue
driving because protesters were standing
in front in that context the use of the
hammer may have been in self-defense so
this is not a good faith actor he first
reports that nt4 brandished hammers then
when it becomes undeniable that it was
the right wingers who brandish the
cameras he says all right that's true
the opposite what I reported is true but
it was plausibly in self-defense so not
a good faith actor even though he's been
lauded by the right and then the cherry
on top is that you know now has been
caught on video commiserating with a
far-right group that was planning
violence and he never reported that they
were planning this violence the group is
called patriot prayer they were planning
violence knows on video hanging out with
them as they plan it he reported nothing
and now it has been announced that he is
no longer with quill at the publication
for which he worked now colette is
saying that the separation is not
directly related to the fact that he's
been exposed as commiserating with
right-wingers mining violence and said
nothing about it they say he actually
left colette weeks ago and they're only
announcing it now maybe that's true
maybe it's not i don't know the truth of
that so the big picture is first of all
not surprisingly someone that the right
decided to hold up as both a martyr and
a hero of sorts is not either of those
things and really is a bad fate actor
who was attacked and i am against the
violence and he shouldn't have been
punched in milkshake okay i want to be
absolutely in totally clear but when you
put it all together I just see a
troubled guy quite frankly the
combination of his completely dishonest
and contradictory reporting alright so I
think you get this is that this is my
take I haven't said that much about this
guy because I just haven't haven't cared
but there's been enough attention now
where I felt that there it was time to
do a commentary so that's basically a
bad faith actor caught now doing a bunch
of stuff it's no good and it's it's just
horrible stuff okay I don't know that
I'm gonna be talking about him again
very soon let's see oh you too
recommending to me my own appearance on
Joe Rogan that's cool now like that
all right let me get caught up with
cheers and all sorts of different stuff
stoical Seneca subscribed with prime now
I don't know if I already did this
turkey bacon and cheese cheered thirty
five hundred and one bits and then RJ
seeded five thousand is this another
round or not I can't even tell no that's
okay I already did that one can't think
up a name subscribed with Prime and oh
actually not that much has happened okay
interesting yeah that's an interesting
expression there okay I do finally have
some new members to thank Brandon
Richardson is new member number three of
the evening Bennett Marco is new member
number four of the evening and Troy
Spitz Miller is new member number five
of the evening so let me update we are
not at 2 out of 15 we are at 5 out of 15
if people want to call in I will allow
people to call in I will unblock the
phone lines if we get 10 more members
infos over there it's on the website
stuff up there it's all happening and
very very straightforward okay let me
see if I have any other messages to read
no it doesn't appear to be I don't think
so
okay I've been rocking a sweet shirt in
my recent videos all right well thank
you okay let's take a look at this
article I bookmark this sort of earlier
I have not read it I want to see what
the deal is why it was easier to be
skinny in the 1980s a new study finds
that people today who eat and exercise
the same amount as 20s people 20 years
ago are still fatter I'm gonna guess it
either has to do with what we are eating
or it has to do with outside of the
defined exercise time that people are
just more sedentary let's take a look
there's a meme aimed at millennial
catharsis called old economy Steve it's
a series of pictures of a late 70s
teenager who presumably is now a
middle-aged man that mocks some of the
messages Millennials say they hear from
older generations and shows why they're
deeply Genki old economy Steve graduates
and gets a job right away old economy
Steve worked his way through college
because tuition was for
dollars and so forth we can now add
another one to that list Old Economy
Steve ate at McDonalds almost every day
and he still somehow had a 32-inch waist
okay a study published recently in the
journal obesity research and clinical
practice found it's harder for adults
today to maintain the same weight as
those twenty to thirty years ago did
even at the same levels of food intake
and exercise authors examined blah blah
blah they group data sets by amount of
food and activity age and BMI and they
found a surprising correlation a given
person in 2006 eating the same amount of
calories taking in the same quantities
of macronutrients okay like protein and
fat exercising the same amount as a
person did in 88 would have a BMI about
2.3 points higher in other words people
today are about 10 percent heavier then
were people in the 1980s even with the
same diet and exercise see this already
seems weird because BMI does not
necessarily tell you I mean yes heavier
but BMI is such a flawed measure it
doesn't necessarily tell you whether it
correlates to health I don't know about
this
our study results suggest that if you're
25 you'd have to eat even less and
exercise more than those older to
prevent gaining weight however it also
indicates there may be other specific
changes just what those changes might be
are still a matter of hypothesis three
different factors were suggested first
more chemicals that might be weight gain
inducing okay that's what I mentioned
pesticides flame retardants substances
may be altering hormonal processes and
tweaking the way our bodies put on and
maintain weight second prescription
drugs have risen dramatically since the
70s and 80s SSRIs antidepressants many
have been linked to weight gain finally
the microbiomes of Americans may have
somehow changed since the 80s it's well
known some types of gut bacteria make a
person more prone to weight gain and
obesity Americans are eating more meat
than a few decades ago that's actually
surprising I didn't think that was the
case many animal products are treated
with hormones and antibiotics yeah okay
so it doesn't seem like we have
fantastic
fantastic sense of what is necessarily
causing it but there are some ideas I
guess a lot of people talking about
prescription drugs seem like the most
likely thing hormones pesticides
chemicals in the water antibiotics I
need to be vegan one person really wants
me to be vegan I guess okay no mention
of cocaine my bet is on stress as stress
yeah I mean that stress is not mentioned
here there's nothing lifestyle related
mentioned here and it feels like it
probably should be don't you think seems
like it to me okay the article was less
interesting than I thought
and for that I since sincerely
apologized to you I thought the reason
you gained weight with SSRIs was because
you ate more well this is saying given
the same amount of food consumption
stress and lack of sleep means even your
workouts are less effective people in
the 80s didn't have exercise you know
the article was boring it was boring I I
sincerely apologize for that I thought
that was not that was not a good thing
for me to do should I be reading like
you where you reword things yeah that's
funny
I that's a habit because even when I
have for my show even when I have notes
even though I wrote the notes I am
constantly rewording just the way I feel
like saying things at the time and I
just do it automatically
even when I'm like reading an article
it's kind of a weird thing have I
invited Michael Parenti on my show not
only have I invited him I believe that
I've interviewed him let me take a look
Michael Parenti it's crazy I don't
remember but I've done like 1500
interviews
yes I believe I've got it here's Michael
Parenti
I will of course watch the ad because
it's my own channel just kidding I'll
skip it yeah here's Michael print today
are a component of Corporate America I
mean they're giant corporation clearly
using some kind of strange screens on
their boards of directors there sit the
the CEOs of various different
corporations of oil industry the auto
industry transportation Monsanto always
they actually sit on the boards of the
big okay anyway we don't have to do the
entire thing but I've I've interviewed
Michael Parenti and people can check it
out if they want okay let me say thank
you to Zachary
a Shulman Zachary Eshelman is new member
number six of the evening so here's my
suggestion I'll still stream for a while
longer I'm not going anywhere quite yet
but if people do want to call in it
sucks when I have time to take like two
phone calls so if people are interested
in me opening the phone lines and I
would be glad to do it
at six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's just get these last
nine website members out of the way and
then we'll take a but watching ads on
your own channel is against YouTube's
Terms of Service yeah I mean I can't
control it the ads just show up I don't
know what people are supposed to do
about that and by the way this is I'm
watching on my personal account not my
business account so maybe that's
different if people want me to open the
phone lines I'm glad to do it
but I want some time to actually take
phone calls so I would suggest let's
just head over to my website not that's
the straw poll here it is head over to
join pakman.com sign up there's coupon
codes it's cheap it's all great stuff
and if we get nine more I will thank all
of you fine folks profusely and I will
open the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty in
the meantime because voicemail is on
it's funny people are just blowing up
the phone line right now and leaving
voicemails let me see what kind of
voicemails are coming in just because
it's funny
c-note thanks for the twitch Prime
subscription snaf thanks for the twitch
Prime subscription also thanks to sky
LARM for five bits and then twenty more
bits I appreciate that very much
do I consistently use a teleprompter
yeah I mean I have I have a sort of a
prompter I've got a monitor below my
camera in the studio and it has my notes
on it
and you know the guest introduction and
stuff like that okay let's see what kind
of it's like people are just calling and
calling and calling we do have Oh Jimmy
from Philly the crazy trumpet okay look
let's make a deal I'm gonna play a
voicemail from Jimmy from Philly who is
incredibly angry and this is sad but
heavily drinking trumpet if you think
that this is compelling stuff sign up
for a website membership because this
will get live callers who may be as
entertaining as Jimmy let's take a
listen together
daddy beat Jimmy from Tony why are you
coming on to YouTube like you're live
now and when I look into hours ago right
Jimmy has been contacting me there's
this weird thing let me make sure I do
this off off stream Jimmy from Philly
Jimmy from Philly has been emailing me
one two three four times in the last six
weeks saying David why don't you
announce streams anymore I just never
hear about your streams and of course
you know I have no control over that if
he is set up to be notified of my
streams he would be notified of my
streams and then two hours after my
streams he leaves voicemails like these
saying I'm being disingenuous because he
wasn't notified about the fact that I
was going to be streaming I mean it just
it's it's it's crazy Jimmy is in the
chat is that right is Jimmy and on
twitch I'm not seeing him here Jimmy
where is Jimmy
I don't see Jimmy and chat I'm sure that
the user named hipster King is not
actually Jimmy okay everybody's saying
that they are Jimmy got it
so Jimmy is not here very good
everybody's Jimmy in some sense let's
see what else we've got on the voicemail
line here's a voicemail from someone who
likes Andrew yang I did it uh I've
listened to the one on the economy so
free speech I hope we can see more of
these in the future I would like to see
more videos about things like climate
change all right well very good I
appreciate that comment let's see what
other voicemails are coming in just just
for kicks all of these folks could be
talking to me live if we opened up the
phone lines let's see I'm trying to go
let's go for this caller hey David I
really love the show um I really wish I
could have talked to your life but
voicemail number is always three - just
a quick question
I wanted to know regarding the electoral
college let's say we have a progressive
candidate as a primary the Democratic
elect to be or whatever terminology you
want to use or whatever the correct
terminology is what happens if the
Electoral College just kind of does what
they did back in 2016 like um
Hillary kind of Hillary Clinton won the
popular the general the general vote but
then the Electoral College said nope
we're gonna go ahead and take that back
and we're gonna like Donald Trump what
happened to that happens in 2020 where
do we go from there well it's quite
possible that it will happen I mean I
did that's just it's the system we have
it wouldn't change anything people who
want to abolish the Electoral College
are gonna continue to say we need to
abolish the Electoral College oh the
serfs is the serfs are in the chat great
to see you talked a little bit about our
interview earlier and we watched some of
the
Alex Jones thing with Sargon Akkad as he
referred to him let's see what other
interesting voicemail we might have it's
hard to know what's interesting just
from looking at area codes both hello
David hey would you do everybody save
for her and announce on your website put
it prominently when the live shows are
streaming and also when you take live
phone calls right so we take live phone
calls for the broadcast show Wednesdays
at 12:15 p.m. Eastern Time
I don't usually announce the streams
because I planned them pretty last
minute as a general thing so that's why
let's listen to another one yes I think
you should be aware that the USCIS has
now decided that military's diplomat and
anyone who is an American citizen the
hands of child outside the United States
their children are no longer American
citizens no that's not happened there's
a discussion of repealing birthright
citizenship and Trump has talked about
it but that's that's that's just not
that's not true okay let's take a listen
to another one well they David it's
William from Quebec Canada I just had a
question about something that I know
comes up a lot in UK politics but it's
not really talked about a lot in the
u.s. it's austerity so I know there's a
lot of talk in Europe about austerity
like it happened in Greece and my
question is it's like was austerity in
Greece really necessary from my
perspective I mean it it's hard it's
hard to know because they had a really
bad debt problem but then on the other
hand is debt really meaningless so in
general what's your take on austerity
and yeah that's about it
Thanks all right I've dealt with that on
the show a bunch of times we're not
going to do that right now this is why
we pre-screen them by the way now I am
curious there's a voicemail here that's
more than five minutes long that makes
me extremely curious should we see what
someone would say and a five-minute long
voicemail for whatever reason that is
piquing my interest
people want that okay let's take a look
hi David my name is Anthony Holland I'm
a truck driver and I am calling from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania uh the reason
for my call I was watching a clip of
your show today I'm a stand by the way I
think you are brilliant very insightful
and I miss skip ahead a little bit and
listening to your show just helping in
to iron out my opinions and make sure
that it's solidly back so I want so I
want to first let you know that I
appreciate your perspective I appreciate
the work that you do and it's people
such as yourself that are going to move
our society forward in a positive manner
now on to a critique of her today please
I heard you discuss the issue with
Donald Trump and why people need to come
together to get him out of office and
you know and a lot of the reasons why
you feel he got elected and I want to
talk about what you didn't include that
I feel is the most pressing issue and
the reason that Donald Trump is in
office is primarily because of racial
resentment the Republican Party has been
using racist dog-whistle politics for
years now we can talk about how McCain
was a stand-up guy but he used a dog
whistle okay I think I get where he's
going so yeah listen that is a part of
it but it is not all of it there is the
fear of losing status real or perceived
that motivated a lot of Trump voters
there there are numbered there is hatred
of Obama quite frankly there's a bunch
of different stuff I think I kind of get
where where he was going with it okay
Brandon Keith is this evenings newest
david pakman show member that gets us to
7 of 15 new website members and if we
get eight more I will open up the phone
lines okay let me take a look at the
other thing I wanted to look at was what
was happening on
i subreddit the subreddit now has nearly
14,000 members I I believe been saying
and it may be true who cares if it's not
but I've been saying that I believe this
is the one of the largest progressive
independent media subreddits out there
thirteen thousand nine hundred members
it may not even be true but I've been
saying it and I think that it's great
okay I didn't choose the grift life it
chose me Candace Owens what do you want
to be when you grow up grifter grifter
grifter okay
David's been calling it for a while now
yeah I'm gonna cover this on tomorrow's
show Trump tweet Trump is basically
turned on Fox News at this point and we
have I've been saying for months that
Trump may well turn on Fox News and that
if he does he will probably go to oh way
n let's actually do that let's check out
the one America news network because
this is the one American news network
looks like a parody of what a right-wing
channel would look like if people
haven't heard of this you are going to
be shocked and appalled let's take a
look at it here so it just it looks like
satire when you look at this all of the
images seem like they would be satire
let's just pick a clip which one let's
look at their recent uploads what do
people want does do any of these seem
good Oh dr. John Lott this guy's been on
my show he's a gun nut do any of these
look good someone asked me what did I
say you take live phone calls again I
will take live phone calls if we get
eight more website members the counter
is up there and the info is right there
and everybody who signs up I will thank
people wanting which any of these clips
may be just the top by the way it just
it looks like the entire thing is satire
let's look at let's look at this one
what's this about garment district
and ER says that he has a solution to
all of this he has a solution to what is
wrong with journalism he wrote an op-ed
about this believe it or not he blamed
the problems in journalism on media
conglomerates and media mergers he wants
the government's to outlaw all of that
regulate why this woman is I have no
idea who this woman is people seem to
recognize this woman business but it
seems to me that the problem with
journalism in our nation is not media
conglomerates its journalists who lie oh
you're absolutely right look there's a
huge problem in journalism you have
activists activists journalists from the
media's controlled largely by the left i
mean they're they're somewhat untended
of the democratic party but this isn't
anything new from Bernie Sanders he
wants to take over another industry oh
okay I mean he's been calling for the
takeover of multiple industries since
the 70s the oil industry he wanted to
take over the TV industry why does this
look like it would be a porn satire of
right-wing media like this just this
doesn't it doesn't seem like it's a real
show there's just something very very
strange about this it has worse
production value than the onion tane ten
years ago says Burke the jerk yeah I
just I don't understand why it just does
not look real in any way it's very
strange let's look at one other one oh
the Venezuela one people wanted let's
take Venezuela and its economy continue
to spiral into greater despair under the
Maduro regime what America's this guy
looks like he is playing a character of
what a news person might be Lima cabe
spoke to Maria Corina Machado the leader
of the Venezuelan resistance about the
situation there take a look well the
situation in Venezuela is deteriorating
every day that goes by Machado said the
suffering of the people in her country
continues to worsen the regime has
profound it and the repression the
massive repression and the economic
situation is unsustainable people are
dying of hunger a lack of medicine and
that's the reason why we're seeing an
increasing number massive number of
Venezuelans fleeing our country
everything that goes by
in February President Donald Trump spoke
to a gathering of Venezuelans in Miami
about the crisis so today I asked every
member of the Maduro regime and this
nightmare of poverty hunger and death
for you people let your people go set
your country free okay so it's just like
sycophantic Trump stuff
oh here's the new information about
Hillary's Dropbox the investigation
Hillary Clinton's use of a private email
server continues what America's has the
latest on those developments a newly
declassified Senate report details new
look at May sky look at this guy
Jackie's open about hillary clinton's
illegal email server one american news
has previously reported that this server
held classified information including
information about so-called this guy's
two years younger than me can you this
is insane this guy looks like he's 50
doesn't he take a look here this is
insane
jack fizeau biack 1985 isn't all okay so
he's a year younger is an alt light
pro-trump activist role writer and most
importantly completely insane conspiracy
theorist who has a press pass at the
White House before hopping on the Trump
train Pozo biak had a relatively small
internet presence running a game of
Thrones blog he was also an intelligence
officer for the US Navy for a time Pizza
Gate if if you have a pizza gate
subheading on rationale wiki were in
trouble
doesn't this guy look like he's old
enough to be my dad this is DJ's younger
than me for somehow this is this is
crazy look at this guy again or was he
here is as special access programs that
is stunning I mean that is absolutely
stunning okay I think we've done enough
of we've done enough of this stuff I
don't think we need to do more of it
okay let me see who else I need to be
thanking here
oh my guess nobody interestingly that's
sad
all right and yeah the the voicemail
system is almost getting overloaded
actually people are just I guess people
find it fun to call in but leave
voicemails even though the phone lines
are closed huh looks like a kid with an
aging disease that's that's sad charlie
kirk looks like he's 50 oh you know who
called in this is interesting it would
have been nice to actually get get him
on the phone a couple weeks ago I did a
twitch stream and a thirteen-year-old
called in and everybody was like this
kids way to articulate to actually be 13
but he just left a voicemail hey David
it's um
Grayson so I in my opinion cities and
housing are a huge or not talked about
enough in American politics and I was
wanting your ideas about this new
program in Seattle where people
receiving section 8 vouchers would sorry
uh would be shown places around
different neighborhoods so they could
because they have we have a problem
where you're receiving section 8
vouchers off only about 15% of them move
into better neighborhoods appear places
better schools more opportunity very few
people were doing that maybe all that
15% and then they had to increase n to
54% so I was thinking I don't know if
you've heard about that or what do you
thought about that and also do you see
thorium liquid salt reactors as a viable
power source for America okay I need to
do a straw poll who believes that that
kid is really 13 years old I know it's
hard to imagine that a 13 year old cares
about section 8 vouchers I completely
agree with you
stoical Seneca it's just hard to imagine
and he's on the left by the way people
saying it's a Sargon fan it's not this
that's a--that's a left-winger for sure
and a lot of people seem to think he's
between 17 and 19 the consensus seems to
be he's not thirteen but I think he is
he emailed me after the last stream and
said gave me more information about
himself if he's not really 13 he's
playing an extremely good character and
some people are impressed by it
okay what do I think about Greta Thun
burg I know very little about her and I
don't know I I know that a lot of these
kid activists are doing good stuff but I
just I just don't follow it bd9 one one
one says I saw you on Joe Rogan and
thought you were reasonable then I'm
seeing you ad Homme these gentlemen
instead of going for their arguments
guess I misjudged you I don't know who
you're talking about
I mean what I genuinely don't know what
you're talking about
I don't know what ad hominem is you
might be referring to you know okay so
all right let me let me just get to a
few other things I wanted to mention
here okay I mentioned on somewhere I
don't know where it was that during my
vacation last week I actually played
Super Mario Brothers my favorite video
game period is Super Nintendo Super
Mario Brothers I don't know if you're
allowed to talk about emulators on
Twitch there's this really weird thing
but I have it on an emulator and people
have been asking me to play it on streem
because nobody believes that I actually
know Super Mario Brothers like the back
of my hand is that allowed or would I
not be allowed to do that
I can Super Mario World I'm sorry Super
Mario World yeah David please speedrun
it it's okay if you own the game okay I
mean it I don't own the game that's the
truth is I don't own the game you can't
stream emulators you can you just can't
stream emulators play it say you're
playing on a Super Nintendo just don't
say it's an emulator it's not allowed
Nintendo will get you it's absolutely
allowed there are people completely
convinced that it's fine and people
completely convinced that it's not okay
just don't talk about it being on an
emulator by the game it's 50 bucks
oh okay so but we're fine what did like
by where you mean literally by a
cartridge and then I can play it on an
emulator it seems weird
I have to say I own it okay all right I
own it people stream emulators all the
time no it's not allowed
twitch doesn't care I would have you
cannot use emulators I don't know what
that means how would I pretend I'm
playing it on a system if it's on the
screen I just don't understand how how
do I pretend it's okay if you're a girl
streamer somehow I don't think so twitch
enforces rules and consistently twitch
doesn't care it's totally fine
definitely don't do it you can't do it
you can stream but not VOD streamers 50
times bigger than you do it all the time
it's not an emulator wink if you have
the console wink wink right walk into
another room and pretend you grabbed it
yeah but I don't like if it just pops up
on my screen share how am i great how is
it even plausible I don't even
understand
don't snare at the emulator I don't even
know what that means
ask your lawyer my lawyer doesn't know
about this stuff he'll buy the game if
he gets five website subscribers yeah
exactly if we get eight new website
members not only will I open the phones
I will also buy the game and then I will
play it on stream talk to trihex David
doesn't know how video game streaming
works of course I don't
am I asking you how to commit a crime no
I'm definitely not I just did a search
for in terms of service for emulator and
there's nothing there for the emulator
to Baliga legally you've got to own the
game you won't get banned you're a
boomer vapenation 3:11 subscribed with
twitch prime people have been banned but
also people get away from it get away
with it
people they're gaslighting you you blew
it with the conversation trihex would no
call pokiman she is crying is that right
hey let's see who's streaming from the
people that I follow I really want pokey
main to raid the channel at some point
it looks like she is streaming let's
just see what's going on over there she
follows me and stuff and you know I'm
trying to develop a business
relationship with her let's see what
happening I mean if you ever want to do
a food delivery to my place doesn't seem
like she's crying
[Music]
easy clap boys let's see I'm going to
say people told me you were crying but
it seems everything is okay
Oh only subscribers jeez I'm not doing
that are you crazy no I'm kidding I just
don't subscribe to anything I want to
ask a serious question can someone
explain to me watching other people you
learn from them okay like what am i
learning right now people like watching
me not understand minecraft don't
understand let's talk plans okay okay
coming okay that's probably enough right
I mean I think we've probably seen
enough of what's going on there it
doesn't look like it doesn't look like
there's any crying going on which is a
good thing we don't want anybody crying
it's a friendship simulator people like
the talking you build stuff minecraft is
boring call someone there crying is a
meme oh I didn't even and I didn't even
know that I wouldn't even know that
David so innocent that's beautiful
you're not allowed to emulate another
twitch stream I don't even know what
that means
chess is better call David Pakman he's
crying
okay mr. nano pod thanks for subscribing
with twitch Prime I
preciate that can I do a segment on
parasocial relationships maybe title
David Pakman plays Minecraft for the
first time 200,000 views could it what
would I need in order to play Minecraft
do I need to get it on Steam or
something like that I don't even I mean
it's like I'll click around if people
really want me to but it seems quite
boring I'm not gonna lie I need a PC
okay that I've got get the game on the
site emulate minecraft Microsoft Store
not Steam dual PC setup I I don't know
what's going on Kyle kolinsky got
arrested check twitter there's no way
that that is true just for kicks I'm
gonna check Twitter but it's so
impossible to imagine that that's the
case okay he didn't get arrested good
you tricked me you got me but he didn't
um get website memberships you flips is
it just me or were people getting
agitated in the chat I was pumped for a
second that Kyle got arrested no I was
concerned did I make a comment about
Hassan's controversial statement yes at
the beginning of the stream Burnie
slipped on a banana peel let me google
that by the way oh that people see there
people have been saying Oh Bernie
Sanders speed bag people are making fun
of Bernie Sanders for this it doesn't I
mean it's like it's funny but I don't I
don't even really get why people are
making such a big deal out of it I don't
know if people saw this take a look at
this
so this is like only the first four
seconds but if you actually look at the
full like 15 second thing Bernie as a
guy who's nearly 80 years old actually
looks pretty good hitting the bag let me
see I think on Twitter some of the
replies oh that's not it some of the
replies I think had the full video here
it is yeah nothing uh really no big deal
there he played softball the other day
okay let's see here
people oh I guess the the the parasocial
relationship thing was was serious and
people want me to talk to pokey main
about it and close this out Oh things
are paka you know what this is actually
getting dicey because now people are
sending me messages and yeah okay anyway
I don't know what if that's a real
suggestion or if it's not imagine
wanting an eighty-year-old president and
expecting him to be able to fight
someone yeah I mean listen I'd love to
see Trump punch of speed do speed bag
it's just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever okay who should who should I
raid at the end of today's stream let's
discuss that because now I am on the
rating bandwagon who is it that pokey
says she will play Minecraft with you if
you buy it david pakman our people
trolling me or is that true because it
seems like playing Minecraft with
someone who has 3.2 million subscribers
would be a good thing do it it's real
it's a troll clip it true do it she said
it okay if she said it
please clip it for me and send it to me
I think people are trolling me clip it
or it's fake host pokey or trihex clip
it or it's fake I'm getting trolled yeah
I'm getting trolled permanently clip it
or zip it trihex is trihex streaming
right now let me see I only follow a few
people on
which trihex I don't actually even know
if he's streaming oh he is streaming all
right I think that's a good idea I don't
think I've actually he's playing Yugi Oh
guys I know has saunas banned I'm not
stupid
now I'm not gonna do Chapo cuz I have no
I have no relationship with chapo so I'm
not gonna be doing that
okay let's raid trihex let's absolutely
do it sadly we didn't get to live calls
today but hopefully next time let's
let's let's raid trihex we're gonna do
it big time things we're going over
there trihex is crying okay good then
it'll be a good thing to get over there
let's go